[Musique]
c'est une épidémie dans l'épidémie de
kovy din al atteint les yeux les simus
la mâchoire le cerveau dans le pire des
cas
ce champignon rare mais redoutable peut
tuer en quelques jours ce n'est pas
détecté à temps en inde la muco remis
cause se répand un rythme inquiétant en
particulier parmi les convalescents du
prophétisme en quoi ce champignon et le
coc u19 sont ils liés et comment lui
convient peut-il être en partie
responsable de cette maladie rare telle
arrivée en france
réponse dans actu high poly où le cinéma
est aussi actionnaire et chirurgie
ophtalmique basée à mumbai en inde
le nombre de patients qu'il reçoit
atteint par ce champignon explose depuis
que l'inde est durement frappée par sa
deuxième vague de couronnes à virus
avant la pandémie l'inde n'enregistrer
qu'une vingtaine de cas d'une cormick
aux parents mais ces trois derniers mois
plus de soixante mille cas de
champignons noirs ont été recensés dans
le pays
mais le public en soit les neuf et sa
finesse entre nous allez ciao le
champignon à l'origine de la mycose est
pourtant tout à fait banal il est
présent partout dans les sols les fruits
les légumes peut être même dans votre
jardin et dans la majorité des cas il ne
pose pas de problème
oui mais avec ce qu'il en est des listes
d'admis any of america d'infection
brésil
[Musique]
des champignons qui sont aussi dans le
monde de l'alimentation puisque par
exemple pour faire du tofu c'est du soja
fermenté avec des moisissures et parmi
ces mesures ils aident les core i7 qui
sont donc parfois responsable d'une peur
diffuse donc ça veut dire qu'il faut pas
les craindre à ses champignons les
rencontres tout le temps dans notre
environnement mais il ya certaines
situations dramatiques où il ya une
évolution a fait lundi à l'image du coc
vide dont les formes graves sont rares
chez les personnes sans comorbidités ce
champignon affecte surtout les personnes
immunodéprimées comme celles atteintes
du sida ou encore diabétiques
il s'avère que l'inde est le deuxième
plus grand nombre d'adultes atteints de
diabète au monde et surtout à bagdad
[Musique]
alors le coc vide dans tout ça
typiquement lorsque l'on attrape le coc
u19 notre système immunitaire s'emballe
dangereusement
les médicaments administrés comme les
stéroïdes ont pour but de calmer cette
réponse immunitaire
or chez les personnes immunodéprimées
dont le système immunitaire est déjà
fragile c'est très dangereux car cela
favorise les autres infections comme
celle du champignon noir ce qui
expliquait qu'en inde
parmi tous les cas de mon corps me
causent près de 85 % d'entre eux avec
hulk au vide autour de lui suspecte et
la victime jean dose on dit respect tout
ce qui est interdit en cause des locaux
en belgique
malgré les craintes des médecins au tout
début de l'épidémie de connected 9
il ya toutefois très peu de chances que
la maladie pour l'hiver ainsi
en france ce sont des maladies
extrêmement grave que l'on connaît à des
niveaux très faibles au nouveau
programme par exemple chez les patients
qui sont près des immunodéprimés avec
les leucémies essentiellement ex
contemplant quelques dizaines de cas par
an maximum en france depuis une
infection par le service coque de on a
craint qu'il y ait une flambée est en
fait là aussi on pense le nombre de ces
infections est notamment car il est
généralement détectée bien plus tôt en
france qu'en inde
même si le taux de mortalité de cette
maladie reste extrêmement haut autour de
50% minimum en plus en france ce sont
surtout des formes pulmonaires de la
maladie que l'on observe notamment que
les séjours en réanimation des patients
atteints du coït 19 et non pas des cas
qui atteignent le nez les sinus ou
encore le cerveau comme en inde où les
chirurgiens sont parfois obligés de
procéder à l'ablation de ces parties
afin que l'infection n'atteignent jamais
le serment dessus de nous nous autres
raisons
négligeable en inde de nombreux médecins
mettent en cause depuis bien longtemps
les conditions d'hygiène dans certains
hôpitaux pouvant favoriser la
prolifération de ces champignons et la
multiplication des contaminations
[Musique]